répondant lagaf' de cabine en famille
les enfants sur l'ancien déporté et là
ça nous arrive après chacun besoin de
voir la communauté iq routes en 1978 le
rabbin de drancy effondré après l'
incendie de sa synagogue c'est l'un des
premiers cas d'actes antisémites depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale ils
deviennent récurrents dans les années 70
et sont relatés de jt en jt en 1981
l'attentât de la rue copernic à paris le
premier depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale fait quatre morts
ils ont voulu commettre un attentat qui
atteindrait le maximum de personnes ya
des femmes et d'enfants à l'intérieur de
la synagogue qui prit c'est une
synagogue libérale est donc
véritablement c'est un acte odieux que
tous les français j'en suis certain
condamneront 1990 année déplorable dans
la nuit du 8 au 9 mai 34 tombes juives
du cimetière de carpentras ont été
profanées par des jeunes néonazis
des corps ont été exhumés alors que le
front national et ses thèses racistes et
antisémites gagne du terrain alors que
l'antisémitisme semble monter depuis des
années la population se mobilise après
carpentras au total partout en france
deux cent mille personnes sortent dans
la rue ce soir nous sommes tauscher
juifs et antiraciste nous refusons ce
que dit monsieur le pen parce que c'est
probablement ces mots là qui ont poussé
à ces actes là à partir de 1998
le ministère de l'intérieur recense les
cas de menaces et des actions à
caractère antisémite
leur nombre est très variable année
après année le pic est atteint en 2004
avec 974 actes enregistrés l'an passé à
tabac ils m'ont arraché la médaille mon
signe religieux un cinéma hic une croix
gammée et une inscription les juifs
dehors rappelle les années les plus
sombres de notre histoire
chaque acte antisémite est une agression
contre la france toute entière contre
chaque français ces dix dernières années
ont été marquées par des attentats
islamistes 2012 l'attentât de l'école
ozar hatorah à toulouse quatre morts
2015 lippert cacher dans la foulée de la
tuerie de charlie hebdo cinq morts
cible du néonazisme de l'islam radical
ou d'auteurs aux motivations floues
la communauté juive reste impuissante et
ce malgré les lois de plus en plus dure
vis à vis des auteurs d'actes
antisémites
[Musique]